the 1995 Academy Awards for science and
technical achievement were presented at
a lovely dinner three weeks ago at the
Regent Beverly Wilshire hotel nominees
were treated to a choice of roast beef
or snapper also live music in a cash bar
all this was the Academy's way of saying
you people are too dull to be on the
real show here now with some highlights
of those Awards is Arnold Schwarzenegger
stunning co-star from True Lies Jamie
Lee Curtis
weeks ago I had the great privilege of
hosting the banquet honoring the
extraordinary contributions of the
scientific and technical community it
was a wonderful affair we had a lot more
fun than you are and even though we may
then precisely what the award winners
accomplished you and I the movie-going
public are all the beneficiaries of
their vision and dedication during the
evening many awards were given out and
we mentioned two in particular this
evening as the winners of the highest
honor the Academy can bestow the Oscar
the first Oscar went to a father and son
for their concept and development of the
ultimate electronic blue screen
compositing process first accept with
Hasani Hall Bluffs I'm going to cherish
this award in this moment forever thank
you next came the father
fire Oscar winner Petzval lost profits
thank you thank you thank you
development and production of an
exceptional quality film he spent the XR
color film 5244 accepting was the
chairman president and CEO mr. George
Kodak moment folks
thank you to the Academy to its great
president Arthur Hiller to the
scientific and technical committee thank
you on behalf of Eastman Kodak
the Academy the Academy congratulate all
of the men and not one woman who were
honored that night and thanks them for
their ongoing quest for the next
frontier bye
please welcome the star of the Santa
Clause Tim Allen